new york announced they wouldn't be
doing the 911 memorial
the light show and it is
uh this they're not going to do it
because of code concerns
my understanding is that another
non-profit stepped up yep
to make sure it happens yeah they're
gonna do they're gonna do it by like any
means necessary they were saying they're
like this is not
something that we're willing to put
aside and i don't think they refer
to for example the blm mark in the
street or anything
but they were very serious about it
they're like i think it was the sba
uh uh the some association of police
officers and they were like we're not
gonna let this slide
which i thought was great i'm really
happy to see that like i'm happy to see
normal people saying this is something
that's important
and you're not just gonna take it away
from us because if you're healthy enough
to be
raising cane in the streets and painting
stuff on the streets then why are you
telling us that we can't do this
you could literally just push the button
yeah it looks like this it's a memorial
for the twin towers and they're like we
can't do it because coronavirus oh
yeah which is a lie uh total lie total
lie like
why what's their reasoning it's kovid
they say it requires a large team to
pull off and it's a lie
and the reason i say it's a lie is
because they're marching with black
lives matter
they're using city resources to to paint
the ground
i gotta be honest this in my opinion is
if if this story you know
goes viral i really don't think
biden and harris could win i mean first
trump needs to address it
yeah and i wonder what biden and harris
would actually say about it
but nothing absolutely nothing they will
not address this at all
i'm to be fair joe biden said that
antifa people should be arrested
you know and charged i will i will make
a gentle person's bet
gentle persons you're so politically
correct i am indeed a gentle person's
bet
and you guys are welcome to take me they
will not say a single word about this
but will trump i think he will and it
might be late it might be too late to do
anything
but i think he'll bring it up at some
point right now there's
so for politically the opportunity to
address it
is now yeah because apparently there's
other groups that are going to step in
and they're going to make sure it
happens yeah
but i got to tell you this man what do
you think the average american is going
to be thinking
when they see bill de blasio painting
black lives matter
and then new york city saying no 9 11
memorial it's obviously inconsistent
i'm not saying bill de blasio is the one
you know orchestrating the shutdown of
the memorial
what i'm saying is you have a city where
the mayor can
defy the law with no permit right paint
his political slogan in front of someone
else's building
well they're usually someone else's
building right in front of trump's
building
then have then if taxpayer resources
fund the cops we're going to stand there
and we can't make the 911 memorial
happen that's
that's that's a horrifying indictment on
our our country
yeah and the people of new york but that
being said of course people immediately
stepped up to try and make sure this
does happen
well i don't know if it's still going to
happen but they're straight up saying
so for now it's not right and there's i
forgot the other non-profit as they said
they're going to do whatever they have
to to make it work right and you know
bill de blasio was talking about how
black lives matter transcends politics
you want to talk about something that
actually transcends politics
commemorating 9 11 because that affected
everyone
it brought the whole country together
and it still is something that every
single person in every single party
should remember
yeah like this is not something to mess
around with and i i hope that people
remember it
honestly because that's something
that we should well if it kind of feels
like the country's falling apart and if
we cut if we could come together around
something that would actually make us
feel some kind of brotherhood with our
neighbors it should
yeah do you know the date of the pearl
harbor bombings yeah what is it december
7th 1944.
see i don't i don't remember that it
yeah that date no it was a day that will
live on an infamous i know
and in chicago when you take the train i
think it's the orange line train
from the south side into the loop there
was a building i always remember
that it had pearl harbor and 911 painted
on it
and it was like never forget and it
showed both that's cool
yeah i don't know if it's still there
yeah i'd be curious we should pull up
google maps
well i was a trained line i don't know
you might be able to
but i remember seeing it and you know i
i i didn't remember the date
obviously i remember 911 i was alive i
was you know 14 or whatever watching it
happen
and when it come when pearl harbor i
don't know 70s
it what what's that what no no what was
the date you said
okay it was december 7th 1944 yeah yeah
yeah so i think the reason i remember is
because i used to work with old people
yeah and i i would talk to people about
what they were doing and i asked them
what they were doing
on the day that pearl harbor happened
and some of them could tell me
and that was really interesting because
it was so different from 911
but the emotion was definitely still
there and i was like
so you guys weren't like sitting around
the tv like we were but you were
listening to it on the radio
huh that's really interesting she's and
this lady i was talking to
um was like yeah it brought
everyone together very similar to the
way 911 did
and i think that they're do they want
the division that we have in this
country do they think this is good is
this what they're trying to fight by
getting rid of the 911 memorial i don't
know i'm just
spit bond just kind of theorizing but
the reason i brought it up and asked you
if you knew the date yeah sorry about
that
yeah yeah i have no idea why i said 70s
i don't know what i was thinking
very very off because you said seventh
and i was like wait what did you say did
you say seven
not right yeah no that's clearly wrong
but uh
i was thinking about we're gonna have a
generation of young people
that were either born after 9 11 which
is
a lot of people right now yeah a lot of
them uh like the tic tac generation
and there's going to be a lot of people
who were born at a certain point where
they were too young to
remember it yeah and they're not going
to remember it
and so when that point hits i think in
maybe 10 or 20 years
you will see the memorial lights get
turned off one night
and that's that's a night when people
are going back i don't know whatever
right now it's not that makes you sad
yeah
i mean do we still do anything for pearl
harbor like in this regard
no maybe maybe maybe you know in pearl
harbor you know i think i think
politicians do and at pearl harbor they
actually do have memorial like tours and
stuff
um i think they give speeches on pearl
harbor day not that i can recall any of
them immediately offhand
yeah but i think they do commemorate it
at the kind of national level it's kind
of crazy
you know weird but i i was reading this
earlier
and i'm just i'm just offended you know
what i mean
there should be no circumstance where
this story should need to be
reported the city i believe the city
should be able
so let me read the context real quick
just so i can you know properly explain
what's going on
the new york post says the iconic lower
manhattan 911 memorial display that
features twin beams of lights to honor
victims of the terror attacks will not
shine this year over chronovirus
concerns
organizers said thursday the annual
tribute in light
display requires a large crew to pull
off the 911 memorial and museum said on
its website posing health risks this
year
that were far too great the museum said
it was an incredibly difficult decision
to nix the lights but announced an
alternative citywide initiative to
commemorate the
19th anniversary of september 11th the
new plan dubbed the tribute in lights
will feature buildings across the city
lighting up their facades and spires in
blue on 9 11.
in a spirit of unity and remembrance the
city will come together for a tribute
and lights to inspire the world and
honor the promise to never forget
many iconic new york city buildings will
be lighting their spires and facades in
blue to honor those killed on 9 11.
the decision to cancel the tribute in
light memorial comes into the museum
this year
also scrapped the in-person reading of 9
11 victims names the annual ground zero
ceremony
but last week a non-profit the tunnel to
towers foundations announced its own
separate lower manhattan ceremony
where select family members of 9 11
victims will be permitted to read the
names of their loved ones
i think we're in trouble it's it's scary
to me
that they will paint black lives matter
in the street and arrest anyone who dare
oppose them
without permitting and they will not
read the names of 9 11 victims
to me it really feels like they're just
pulling for division
and i hate to see that but it's making
me really suspicious what else would you
call this
well i know it's not the city
that's deciding it right but don't you
like
is it fair to say that there's some kind
of cultural problem we're having
if there's no resources for this event
why couldn't bill de blasio without
permit pull taxpayer funding to
guarantee
the reading of the 9 11 victims names so
it shows misprioritization
for sure and it shows that people like
bill de blasio just have way
too much power which i think we already
knew but
this is really they're not supposed to
have that power of course not the
problem is the people who just go along
with whatever they say
right when are you gonna throw a fit and
make something happen you know
how how do you how do you prevent
something like that because
our system is of course naturally
hierarchical
and you have police they're like i know
my boss had to go do this
it's like well do you know what you're
doing is illegal right doesn't matter my
boss said do it
you know what i think i'm gonna sound
like i'm beating a dead horse and i
think you're probably gonna agree with
me but i'll say it again
i think that the reason we're having
this problem is because it's been good
for so long it's been too good for too
long we've forgotten what it's like
we assume that things are the way they
are and that everyone's
got our best interests at heart and
we've forgotten that you know our
great-great-grandparents were pioneers
and that our grandparents fought in wars
and
that this is actually something special
and different and we don't travel that
much
we don't see other countries so we're
like all right so this creep we don't
pay any attention to it
we just kowtow to whenever someone tells
us you're gonna do this it doesn't
matter if it breaks constitutional law
or whatever
we're gonna do it because uh that's the
way things are oh man so what you're
saying is
the people of this country weren't
sleeping while their roommates were
stacking objects on top of them
they were awake yeah but stoned yes
i think so that they like and and
immediately all of the stoners are like
how dare you
i'd push the dislike button if i didn't
have to get up kidding i'm kidding
it's a joke uh yeah i think you're right
though because sleep is something
relatively involuntary
and being sta being like drunk or stoned
is something
doubters yeah and downers you're kind of
sleepy you're out of it i guess you're
like i feel good man
i don't know they're stacking stuff on
top of me but i don't care that's a
problem for future me
and then yeah yes yeah and then they're
like about to balance the gigantic
wrench on top of your head and you're
like oh man that might fall and it does
it hits your toe and you're like
you're freaking out and now it's finally
so bad but you didn't do enough before
i don't think i i honestly i don't know
if there's like an actual way to solve
that without some kind of different
system
i know a lot of people love to bring up
starship troopers yeah have you read
starship troopers you haven't
seen the movie no i've only heard like
little snips about it
and it makes me want to read it and
watch the movie we should watch the
movie
movie
night yeah the movie is weird because
apparently like the interpretation of
the book
in movie form like turned everyone into
nazis well that's annoying
yeah like sargon did a thing about it
where
he was basically like so the stars the
society of stars at troop
starship troopers is supposed to be a
liberal society yeah i don't know i'm
not going to pretend to know all the
details i'm sure you know sargon
is knows way more about it than i do but
the the general idea
is that uh service guarantees
citizenship right
if you serve in any way for a couple
years you gain the right to vote and
participate in public matters
civilians have full rights but don't
vote and don't
you know run for office and stuff like
that it was an interesting idea because
it makes sure
that only the people who actually are
working to better
that's interesting to me because you
know when women got the right to vote
similar responsibilities were not
required of them as were required of men
and even then i saw that as being a
problem like i think it's great i think
everyone should have a say in what
happens in the world i think women are
important i think having families is
important and doing whatever you want to
do is absolutely absolutely pivotal
but if you're going to have rights you
should also have responsibilities
men still have the draft and then you
got to have their responsibilities man
so i don't have anything pulled up
definitely definitely fact check me on
this one but
i was reading uh i was reading something
about it
that said one of the big arguments from
women's groups
against the right to vote i remember was
that they didn't want to join the fire
brigade
or like do other public services yeah i
guess
back then for men it was like voluntary
volunteer fire service was mandatory or
something right
vol voluntary it was actually part of
civic duty yeah part of civic duty and
you know voting is obviously part of
civic duty too
that is interesting i remember some of
that anti-feminist propaganda
which sounds terrible now i know but
it's so interesting because you're like
what were these people actually thinking
how could you possibly think that women
don't deserve or don't need the right to
vote
and you read what they're saying and
they're like well we think that it's
important that women be at home and we
don't women
we don't really want women to have the
extra tasks of like
putting out fires should they come up it
turns out women aren't really all that
great at that kind of stuff
and and if you have a weak link in a
fire chain you're gonna have a problem
so so ultimately though they the right
to vote was granted without any
additional responsibility you know what
i need to figure out why that happened
but to be i i don't i don't i'm not in
the fire brigade i don't put out fires
you know i you know what i mean are you
not in the draft oh well that's true
yeah that's the draft man yeah and they
rule they recently ruled i think right
yeah remember when the feminists were
melting down thinking that they might
have to just be housewives now because
how do they they might actually get
equality
the draft is dumb yeah no we can agree
absolutely i think i think the issue
with the draft that people don't
understand or actually the problem with
it was the exploitation of it
right you know people didn't know why we
were going to vietnam right or korea
or these other countries i mean i could
only say i'm like
personally glad that you know the us was
somewhat involved in korea and is now
extremely involved in korea because
south korea is a free and amazing place
you know
putting their weird racism aside that's
right it's fine
korea but uh a lot of people didn't
understand and so they resisted and they
they opposed it thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you